éidment vous êtes particulièrement
observé c'est donc sur ce terrain du
traitement de l'information que l'AFP
comme au demeurant d'autres grands
médias et pas uniquement en France je
pense à la à la bibci se trouve depuis
quelques semaines pris dans une
polémique qui pose en réalité des
questions fondamentales sur la sur
l'information son utilisation et et son
impact sur nos société pour revenir au
cas d'espèce la FP n'a pas utilisé le
terme de terroriste pour qualifier les
attaques perpétrées par le Hamas en
Israël le 7 octobre dernier cette
position a pu choquer ce pour
lesquels cette qualification ne fait
aucun doute vous avez monsieur le
Président précisé la position
déontologique de l'agence dans les
tribunes parues le le 31 octobre dans le
Figaro et et et ce dimanche dernier dans
le monde monsieur shetwin vous vous êtes
également exprimé dans les médias à ce
sujets au-delà de de de de l'utilisation
du du
terme terroriste la couverture des
événements a également fait débat et je
peut le dire au sein de l'agence même
puisqu'il y a eu un un papier paru dans
dans la lettre qui s'est fait écho d'
d'un mail envoyé par un un responsable
important
de de de lafp émettant des des des
critiques sur la façon dont dont les
événements en Moyen-Orient étaient
couverts si la Commission a choisi en en
pleine période budgétaire de vous
entendre c'est donc bien par souci de
clarté de
compréhension pour que vous puissiez à
travers votre intervention et les
questions des sénatrices et des
sénateurs développer votre politique en
la matière répondre à l'émotion qui
n'est pas illégitime évidemment et aux
questions qu'elle soulève que ce
traitement de l'information à suscité je
veux cependant profiter de ce propos
liminire et je pour le faire au nom de
l'ensemble de de mes collègues pour
apporter notre soutien à l'ensemble des
des agents de lafp qui interviennent sur
le terrain dans des conditions qui sont
évidemment extrêmement parfois
compliquées et aussi au péril de leur
vie sans plus tarder je vous propose de
de de prendre la parole pour un propos
liminaire et ensuite bien sûr chacun des
sénateurs et chacun des sénatrices qui
le souhaitent pourront vous interroger
monsieur le Président merci merci
monsieur le Président le Sénat est un
lieu où le débat peut-être nuancé et où
l'écoute est réelle nous nous
réjouissons donc particulièrement de
cette invité
lafp prend très au sérieux les
accusations de biais dont elle fait
l'objet d'abord parce que son statut
voté en 1957 à l'unanimité du Parlement
après un long combat pour l'indépendance
de l'agence dispose c'est son article 2
qu'elle ne peut en aucune circonstance
tenir compte d'influence ou de
considération de nature à compromettre
l'exactitude ou l'objectivité de
l'information
ensuite on le prend très au sérieux
parce que ce n'est pas de n'importe quel
biais qu'il s'agit la plupart des
critiques en France évoquent un biais
propalestinien mais certains n'ont pas
hésité à faire de l'agence un vecteur de
la montée de
l'antisémitisme c'est d'autant plus
grave et infamant que l'AFP est né en
août 1944 à la
Libération grâce à l'action d'une
poignée de résistant bientôt rejoint par
des rescapés de la Choa
pour mettre fin à la propagande et la
censure imposée par l'occupant nazi à
l'office français d'information alors en
place ces accusations sont folles
ell ne sont pas que des propos de
plateau de télévision puisqu'un élu de
la République un député les a reprises à
son
compte les accusations sont parfois
outrancières mais vous avez raison
monsieur le Président le débat sur la
couverture du conflit lui est tout ce
qu'il y a de plus légitime et
attendu toutes les grandes rédactions
aujourd'hui sont secouées par des
discussions internes parfois vives et
l'AFP n'y échappe pas
philchetwin à mes côtés qui est
directeur de l'information de l'agence
est en relation étroite avec ses pères
des grands médias
internationaux et tous disent que c'est
la couverture la plus complexe et
sensible qu'ils ont eu à organiser
depuis qu'ils sont en
poste ce n'est pas surprenant prenez le
le sujet géopolitique le plus complexe
et chargé de passion qui soit ajouter
l'effet de sidération de l'attaque du 7
octobre mélanger avec ces symptômes bien
connus de nos sociétés contemporaines
que sont la polarisation des esprits
l'hystérisation du débat la prévalence
de la société du Commentaire offrez lors
bien sûr la caisse de résonance des
réseaux sociaux et des émissions où ça
clashche et vous obtenez un cocktail des
plus
explosifs la polémique qui nous touche
est né d'un article de presse qui se
scandalisait de ce que l'agence ne
qualifie pas le Hamas de groupe
terroriste en n'appelant pas un chat un
chat l'agence révélait ses noirs
penchants
habilement l'article laissait entendre
qu'une nouvelle consigne venait d'être
donnée en interne de proscrire l'usage
du mot s'agissant du Hamas comme s'il
s'agissait donc d'une consigne sur
mesure ce que l'article ne disait pas
c'est que cette consigne avait plus de
20 ans qu'elle s'appliquait à tous les
mouvement sans exception Boko Haram état
islamique Al-Qaïda j'en passe et que
d'ailleurs au passage la FP n'était pas
seul à appliquer cette règle puisque les
deux grands grands les deux autres
grands acteurs qui font le même métier
qu'elle la société de presse et Rs
suivent exactement les mêmes règles
alors il est facile de moquer la
réflexion éditoriale sérieuse qui a
présidé à l'élaboration de cette règle
en l'assimilant aux discussions
byzantines sur le sexe des anges c'est
tout simplement refuser de chercher à
comprendre ce qu'est le métier d'une
agence on aurait pu s'interroger sur un
biais si la règle avait été changée pour
ce cas
précis pas dans le cas contraire et
j'ajoute à l'intention de tous ceux qui
continuent de manifester le
incompréhension supposons je dis bien
supposons parce que ça ne nous a jamais
effloré l'esprit que nous renoncions à
cette consigne
éditoriale sous la pression des
commentateurs ou d'un certain camp
politique que dirait-on alors là oui on
serait fondé à parler d'une agence sous
influence depuis cette polémique pas un
jour ne passe sans qu'il faille répondre
à une nouvelle
interpellation parfois
la critique est fondée et l'agence n'a
absolument aucun problème à reconnaître
des choix éditoriaux discutable elle l'a
fait publiquement oui elle aurait dû
rendre compte le jour même d'une
projection organisé par les autorités
israéliennes sur les atrocités du 7
octobre elle l'a fait en anglais pas en
français cela a un nom ça s'appelle un
raté qui n'en fait
pas parfois les attaques font sourire
samedi matin je reçois d'un ami un sms
me poussant un tweet et me disant juste
bon courage ce tweet d'un exjournaliste
dont je terrai le nom par charité disait
vous vous demandez pourquoi la FP refuse
d'employer le mot terroriste au sujet du
Hamas voici peut-être un élément de
réponse Phil chetwin directeur de
l'information à la FP était ou est
encore membre du collectif photographers
for Palestine dont le but est de
raconter l'histoire de la Palestine
telle que vécu aujourd'hui filch twin
écrit dans des revues comme electronic
Intifada et prêche dans des mosquées
écossaises il a fallu une journée pour
convaincre ce journaliste que Phil chwin
avait un homonyme entreetemps le tweet
avait gagné plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de
suiveurs mais il arrive que les coups de
sonde pour voir soi
grave ils peuvent menacer alors
physiquement des
personnes vendredi dernier
tous les grands médias internationaux
New York Times CNN rters associété de
presse et
AFP ont dû se défendre de l'accusation
que certains de leurs photographes de
Gaza étaient en réalité au courant de
l'attaque et l'avait documenté non pas
comme journaliste donc mais comme
complice notre rédaction en chef a passé
la matinée à contrôleré toutes les
photos prises par nos journalistes le 7
à regarder l'heure et le lieu d'où elles
avaient été prises autant de temps pris
sur la couverture naturellement nous
avons dû expliquer que nos trois
photographes installés à Gaza qui
travaillent de façon permanente pour
lafp parfois depuis plus de 20 ans qui
sont reconnus par des pris
internationaux se sont mobilisé dès que
l'attaque du Hamas a été connue ils ont
été réveillés par des tirs d'artillerie
et de roquettes se sont rendus alors à
proximité de la barrière entre Gaza et
Israël chacun était identifié clairement
comme journaliste
sur son casque et son gilet par balle
les premières photos à proximité de la
barrière de Gaza ont été réalisé plus
d'une heure après le début de l'attaque
bref ils n'ont fait que leur métier
suivre l'événement à mesure qu'il se
déroulaiit sur le terrain tous les
autres médias attaqués ont pu montrer
comme nous qu'il n'étit en rien coupable
de ce qu'on leur reprochait mais il a
fallu 3o jours à l'organisation qui
avait lancé l'affaire pour reconnaître
que celle-ci était close d'une phase
phrase lapidaire en prétendant qu'elle
n'avait fait que poser des questions et
qu'elle avait été mal comprise
entre-temps le mal était fait les noms
de ces photographes avaient été jetés en
pâture l'espace d'une journée ils ont
été considérés comme terroristes et
alors que nous cherchons tous les moyens
de les évacuer vous imaginez que cela ne
va pas nous aider dans nos démarches
pour qu'ils intègrent la liste des
quelques
chanceux c'est l'occasion pour moi de
dire que si jamais il arrivait un
malheur à l'un quelconque de nos neuf
salariés à Gaza cela susciterait au sein
de l'agence la même émotion que celle
que nous avons connu à l'occasion de la
mort du français Arman soldine en mai
dernier
ou de la grave blessure de notre jeune
photographe libanaise Christina assi
touchée par un tir au Sud Liban il y a
quelques
semaines parce qu'il participe autant
que n'importe quel autre salarié à
l'exercice de la mission d'intérêt
général de l'Agence et même Mme
probablement davantage au vu de la
difficulté de témoigner de ce qui se
passe à
Gaza sachez pour finir que cette
polémique sur le BIA proalestinien prêté
à lafp est purement française qu'on ne
la retrouve nulle part ailleurs elle
sidère nos équipe dans la région
habitués à entendre plutôt que notre
agence fait le jeu
d'Israël nous avons reçu beaucoup de
message privé d'encouragement notamment
nos clients mais je note qu'il y a eu
très peu d'expression publ de soutien au
travail de laafp probablement pour ne
pas être mêlé à une querelle
incandescente comme il paraît qu'on n
jamais mieux servi que par
soi-même vous me permettrez peut-être
que je dise tout simplement qui d'autre
qui d'autre que l'AFP emploie 50
journalistes textes photos vidéos à
Jérusalem Gaza et ramala qui d'autrre
parvenait encore jusqu'à samedi à
envoyer seul des images de
gazaville qui d'autre a diffusé depuis
le 7 octobre 242 reportages je ne parle
pas de simple factuel mais de vraies
histoires construites dont 96 depuis
Israël 53 depuis Gaza et les territoires
occupés qui d'autre pour ne prendre que
quelques reportages de ce matin a
raconté l'histoire de ces jeunes d'un
kibou se ravager qui retournent à
l'école après les enterrements ou
interview le créateur de la série Foda
expliquant pourquoi la guerre à Gaza
avait dépassé tous les
scénarios Maurice Levy a écrit une très
belle tribune intitulée jamais depuis la
Choa la communauté juif de France ne
s'était senti aussi isolée évoquant les
40 Français juifs assassiné le 7 il
écrit qui étaient ces 40 français quelle
était leur vie étaient-ils parents on ne
sait rien d'eux parce que l'on ne veut
rien savoir ni leur nom ni leurs âges ni
ni leur vie ni leur visage lafp a
commencé de raconter la vie de certaines
de ses
victimes grâce à son réseau de
journalistes en contact régulier avec
des familles d'otage et de la presse
israélienne
elle est parvenue hier à identifieré 208
des 239 otages recensés par les
autorités
elle a décompté au moins 34 enfants dont
17 de moins de 10 ans l'otage le plus
jeune est un nourrisson âgé de 9 mois
enlevé dans le kibut rose avec son frère
Ariel 4 ans et ses parents de jeunes
trentenair h octogénaires figurent parmi
les
captifs qui d'autre que l'AFP a fait ce
travail
merci merci monsieur le Président sans
plus tarder on va commencer les
questions avec celle de notre rapporteur
sur la presse Michel logier merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la FP je crois qu'il est
quand même important de de rappeler
comme l'a fait fait le président la fond
que l'Agence France Presse fait partie
des trois plus grandes agences au monde
vous êtes aussi l'image de la France à
l'étranger puisque vous êtes une des
agences les plus représentées alors au
moment où vous êtes mis en difficulté
faut dire les choses quand même avec ces
polémiques ces
critiques déjà je voudrais savoir est-ce
que vous êtes rendu sur place à titre
personnel pour voir un petit peu la
situation comment les choses
s'organisaient
puisque il y a des caricatures aussi
puisque l'Agence France press AFP est
devenu agence France-Palestine en tous
les cas ce sont des propos que j'ai lu
sur certaines sur certains articles euh
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure des des
moyens en terminant votre introduction
moi je voudais que vous nous précisiez
un petit peu quels sont les moyens
permanents qui existent sur ce secteur
du monde et quels sont les moyens
supplémentaires que vous avez pu mettre
en place alors moyens humains et moyens
financiers aussi parce que il y a pas
que les moyens hum aussi les moyens
financiers est-ce que vous avez mis des
moyens supplémentaires depuis le début
de ce conflit je rappelle et vous l'avez
dit mais rapidement mais je rappelle
quand même que non seulement il y a des
dépêches bien sûr pour la presse écrite
il y a aussi les photos et il y a aussi
les repartages vidéos puisqueaujourd'hui
une grande partie de votre activité ce
sont aussi les portage vidéo euh si vous
n'êtes pas allé sur place mais peut-être
que votre directeurinformation pourrait
nous indiquer quelles sont les
conditions de travail actuellement des
journalistes sur le sur le terrain et
puis pour regarder un petit peu
l'importance et tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment dans cette partie du monde
combien avez-vous de de médiia abonnés
qui reprennent l'ensemble enfin qui
bénéficie de votre travail tout
simplement qui bénéficie de votre
travail je vous laisser répondre à ces
premières
questions je précise
que je ne suis pas journaliste comme
vous le savez je n'ai pas vocation à
intervenir dans le débat
rédactionnel si je le fais sur ces
questions c'est naturellement parce que
l'agence en tant qu'entreprise est
attaquéewin journaliste il va prendre ce
type de question merci fabus
euh juste pour dire NON je suis pas allé
sur place depuis les attentats parce que
il y a tellement de boulot à faire sur
place par les équipes que d'avoir le
directeur de l'information là-bas ça en
fait ça ça devient ça va empêcher le
travail jour à jour j'ai visité Israël
plusieurs fois en tant que rédact chef
de l'agence euh et aussi en en tant que
directeur de l'information on était
toujours très bien accueilli par par les
autorités israéliennes euh dans une
manière très positive la priorité pour
nous après à le le 7 octobre c'était de
mettre le maximum de moyens euh sur les
terrain de de faire le boulot euh qui
dans le contexte actuel et quelque chose
qui est fait 24 24 he sur 24 he ça va
dire oui on a mettre une quinzaine d'en
voyers spéciaux euh texte photo ou vidéo
en permanence euh sur les terrain en
Israël
et c'est avec ces moyens on a renforcé
le bureau de Jérusalem mais aussi on on
a des équipes qui qui va partout en
Israël dans le sud pour faire des des
reportages dans dans avec l'armée dans
tous les cubuts qui étaient affectés par
les les événements atroces de 7 octobre
dans le Nord sur sur la frontière avec
le Liban
partout l'idée c'était vraiment de
couvrir toute la société israélienne à
ce moment clé normalement dans quand je
dis normalement encore une fois j'ai
géré plusieurs conflits Israël ou
palestinien notamment des des événements
à Gaza dans le passé c'était toujours
possible de mettre des des renforts à
Gaza pour pour des autres conflit guerre
et cetera cette fois-ci c'est pas
possible normalement on est on a neu
staff en total à Gaza il inclus SEP
journalistes et bien sûr c'est c'est
important d'avoir des autres à côté
d'eux des gens qui viennent ou de
Jérusalem ou ou d'ailleurs pour pour les
aider pour les renforcer pour les guider
dans des moments très difficiles et de
montrer aussi que l'agence avec eux à ce
mot qui qui est difficile
eu si on a réussi
jusqu'ici de de de faire notre boulot
là-bas c'est c'est vraiment cette
mélange de journalist israélien qu'on a
sur le terrain palestinien et étranger
c'est vraiment une équipe très très
mixte en terme de condition de travail
à ça dépend il y a bien sûr en Israël le
c'est la sécurité qui prime ça veut dire
que parfois c'est la question d'accès ça
se
négocie parfois on a besoin de
travailler avec les autorités pour avoir
accès et cetera mais mais bien sûr on
est allé partout dans toutes les
différentes quiibout qui étaient affecté
toutes les les les les les villes qui
étaient
affecté et on a une présence vraiment
dans tout le sud là toutes les images
qui donnent sur Gaza de cidro par
exemple dans le sud même chose dans le
Nord ça ça se négocie ça dépend il y a
bien sûr une situation de sécurité qui
qui est considérable ça veut dire queon
peut pas juste aller n'importe où mais
ça ça c'est un peu notre boulot d'aller
dans dans un maximum différent endroit
deeline et cetera à Gaza c'est autre
chose c'est extrêmement difficile nos
journalistes travaillent dans des
situations très trèsah ils sont dans une
une précarité extrême on a évacué notre
bureau à Gaza City parce que c'est
c'était dans la zone où les Israéliens
nous a demandé tout le monde de de de
fuir on a évacué notre bureau il y a 10
jours de semaines euh je pense c'est
bien connu que notre bureau a souffert
un frappe euh il y a une semaine il y
avait personne dedans mais les les
dommages sur le bâtiment sont sont
considérable euh nos journalistes avec
le famille euh en total c'est
70%
euh sont dans des appartements détente
des des des des des situations très très
très difficile dans dans le sud
Gazin ils font un boulot remarquable
dans les circonstances euh mais ils sont
dans une situation très très très
précaire notamment parce qu'il y Ava des
des frappes qui continuent autour d'eux
certains ont perdu des des membres de
famille euh presque à la moitié ont
perdu le le résidence Le le l' partart
artementou la
maison mais il continue de de de bosser
faire un travail remarquable avec le
bureau de Jérusalem il travaille main à
main jour à jour avec le bureau de
Jérusalem toute la copie passe via le
bureau de Jérusalem il travaille très
bien
ensemble en terme de quantité de clients
c'est je pense on utilise un chiffre
comme 4 5000 autour du monde eu il inclu
des grosses agences qui redistribuent
notre copie les images à d'autres médias
dans dans le P ah il y a presque pas une
grande médiia du monde qui qui qui prend
pas
effet et pour ma part je suis allé au
Liban la semaine du 20 octobre euh je
vous l'ai dit je ne suis pas journaliste
donc aller en Israël m'occuper de la
couverture c'est pas mon sujet en
revanche m'occuper de la sécurité de nos
salariés salait nous avons eu deux
journalistes blessés le même jour où un
reporteur de rters était mort et je suis
allé là-bas logiquement pour rencontrer
les parents aller à l'hôpital voir qu
quelles étaient les conditions de suivi
et au passage puisque nous parlons de
BIA
propalestinien faire un question réponse
au bureau de Beyrouth nous avons une
trentaine de journalistes et j'ai passé
un très seul quart d'heure sur le thème
d'une agence qui était
proisraélienne pour une raison très
simple en l'occurrence
un des deux journalistes qui a été
blessé qui lui a été n'a pas perdu
connaissance et convaincu que le tir
venait
d'Israël il était fou furieux que dans
notre dépêche nous n'ayons pas attribué
la responsabilité parce que nos règles
éditorial ne le permettent pas ça a
donné lieu à tout un déversement
d'émotion assez exactement symétrique de
celui qui se passe à
Paris voilà c'est la réalité qu'on vit
maintenant toutes vos questions ce sera
plus simple en commençant par le
président
retaillot merci je voudrais d'abord
remercier le président la fond
d'organiser cette audition je pense
qu'elle est importante bien sûr il y a
eu la polémique mais l'Agence France
Presse alimente de très très nombreux
organes de presse écrit ou audiovisuelle
en France donc c'est vous avez un rôle
qui est un rôle fondamental et j'oublie
pas que à quelques semaines du du PLF il
y a il y a aussi une contribution des
Français au fonctionnement de la FP et
donc il y a une responsabilité
particulière du contrôle du du Parlement
euh vous avez raison et en tête de mon
propos je voudrais redire que les
reporteurs notamment de guerre pai un
lourd tribut et il faut y penser et on
ne peut pas faire cette ition sans
commencer par cela pour le reste bien
sûr que vous faites un travail difficile
monsieur le Président d'abord parce que
c'est la guerre ensuite parce que
désormais les guerres utilisent pas
seulement les armes mais leur arme est
aussi l'arme de la
désinformation et cette guerre là est
aussi hybride bien que elle se déploie
aussi avec des moyens classiques et et
puis il y a aussi l'aire de la
postvérité des réseaux sociaux de ces
informations qui ne sont pas contrôlées
qui brouille la perception que nous
pouvons avoir de la réalité mais
justement
ça
aussi votre entreprise à une très très
grande rigueur ce que nous avons compris
notamment à travers les premières
questions qui ont été posées par notre
rapporteur Michel
lougier c'est que pour remplir vos
missions vous avez un réseau très
puissant de correspondants on n a pas
parlé peut-être en par nous vous avez
aussi une charte de bonne pratique
déontologique qui doit vous permettre de
traiter information de la façon la plus
distanciée la plus objective la plus
impartiale possible ça c'est
fondamental j'ai trois questions très
rapides à vous poser vous pourrez y
répondre je suis désolé parce qu'en même
temps on a une séance sur le pfss donc
le temps est compté la première chose
c'est comment faites-vous pour
recueillir les information d'ordre
quantitatif sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à Gaza alors que le
principal
et le Hamas et qu'on sait par ailleurs
que il manipule aisément les chiffres
comment vous vous pouvez relayer des
informations quantitatives et où
prenez-vous vos
sources deuxème élément vous l'avez
rapidement évoqué mais je reviens parce
que ça a été un certain nombre de
journaux américains grand journaux
américains grand journaux aussi du soir
français ils sont
revenus sur la frappe sur l'hôpital qui
avait été tropativement imputé et donc
par erreur on le sait désormais à Israël
j'aimerais connaître quelles ont été les
mesures de prudence de précaution de
recoupement que vous avez eu avec
l'information pour que vous puissiez
vous assurer que dans votre dépêche les
les utilisateurs de ces dépêche ne
soient pas trompés sur ce point qui a
été un point quasiment cas d'école en
réalité puisque des grands journaux
encore une fois pas seulement français
se sont fait berner et le trisème point
qui concerne directement la polémique
puisque vous l'avez redit vous avez fait
les deux d'ailleurs tribunes vous avez
eu l'occasion de vous expliquer dans
dans deux journaux du matin et puis un
du soir qui sont tous les deux trèslus
euh vous dites que vous n'aimez pas vous
n'utilisez pas le mot terroriste c'est
une ligne éditoriale générale et pour
autant euh nous avons retrouvé des
dépêches où ce mot est utilisé et vous
le savez et vous attendiez cette
question je la pose
euh 20 février 2020 une menace
terroriste d'extrême droite en Allemagne
7 janvier 2015 juste
après Charlie Hebdo où vous qualifiez
évidemment d'attentat terroriste
l'attentat de Charlie Hebdo et pour
autant vous ne voulez pas qualifier le
Hamas de terroriste alors que la France
l'Union européenne le qualifie
terroriste et et j'ai lu bien sûr les
tribunes dans lesquelles vous vous êtes
justifié mais mais vous comprenez que
c'est difficile à comprendre que tantôt
vous acceptez d'utiliser le terme de
terrorisme et que pour d'autres cas ce
caslà qui paraît tellement évident vous
le refusiez j'ai lu encore une fois vous
contre arguments mais j'aimerais vous
entendre à
nouveau Lord
Arcos c'est à peu près les mêmes les
mêmes questions bien évidemment moi
aussi je suis très embêté parce que bien
évidemment monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur nous
tous ce que vous ce que vous faites
écrire ce que vous publiez vous parliez
de désinformation parce que justement il
y a de tout et beaucoup de hainees sur
sur Twitter et sur les réseaux sociaux
on compte sur vos dépêches pour pouvoir
dire des choses vraies comme le
président reetaillou moi j'ai relevé
aussi et c'est pour ça que je voulais
que vous reveniez dessus le fait que par
exemple quand vous associez à ftin post
sur certaines photos vous parlez bien
d'alqaïda comme organisation terroriste
euh et donc je ne comprends toujours pas
pourquoi est-ce que pour alqaïda euh
vous le mentionnez quand même euh alors
bien sûr en association avec d'autres
journaux mais ce sont vos photos euh et
pas pour le Hamas voilà
adelziane merci euh président
effectivement merci à à vous monsieur
fris et Monsieur Chatwin d'être venu
vous présenter aujourd'hui pour nous
donner des explication des des éléments
de compréhension je dirais sur la
difficulté qu'il y a à mener euh
ce travail de vérité le président Lafond
l'a évoqué cette citation de Kipling on
la retrouve ensuite au 20e siècle la
première victime de la guerre c'est bien
souvent la
vérité moi mes questions elles seront
très rapides la première chose c'est de
bien comprendre et nous expliquer nous
donner des éléments de compréhension sur
lorsque vous parlez comme les autres
grandes agences AP et Reuters cette
règle éditoriale qui veut que dans la
construction d'une compréhension de
faits sur le terrain vous arriviez à
objectif au maximum ces éléments parce
que vous n'êtes pas un journal d'opinion
un organe d'opinion vous êtes un organe
de presse indépendant financé en partie
par le par l'État mais votre travail au
même titre que Reuters ou AP c'est
d'être en capacité de récupérer ses
éléments factuel et moi ce que je
voudrais comprendre et je pense que ça
fait partie des questions qui ont été
posées par le président retaillot par
madame la sénatrice d'os comment cette
règle éditorial cette règle qui vous
permet de rédiger vos dépêche FP va être
ensuite reprise ce travail en fait que
vous faites en interne pour construire
cette pour construire cette
cette proposition éditoriale ma deuxè
question elle posait sur vos sources
d'information effectivement aujourd'hui
sur le théâtre des opérations dans les
zones de combat effectivement on l'
redit la fermeture des canaux
d'information de cette capacité à avoir
des des informateurs des journalistes
sur place les journalistes ont payé un
lourd tribut depuis le début du
conflit plus d'une trentaine de
journalistes qui sont morts sur le
théâtre des opérations aujourd'hui on
l'a évoqué ces questions de sécurité
comment est-ce que vous êtes en capacité
de sécuriser vos vos vos journalistes
vos agents sur place euh à ma
connaissance donc il y a des
journalistes à notre connaissance à Gaza
comment travaill-t-il et comment
sont-ils en capacité de récupérer de
d'obtenir des éléments d'information
pour produire cette information moi très
clairement de mon point de vue j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler dans le passé
avec lafp je comprends aussi les
mécanismes qui sont à l'œuvre dans la
manière dont vous construisez cette
cette cette information la difficulté
évidemment c'est que dans le moment
d'émotion que nous avons vu moment de de
nous avons vécu ce moment de sidération
le 7 octobre puis avec la douleur qui
s'en est suivie les moments de
solidarité d'émotions que nous avons
témoigné à l'égard des victimes des deux
côtés vous ce travail là il est
difficile en tant que journaliste
d'autant plus difficile que vous êtes
cette agence fierté de la France aussi
en terme d'information en terme de
capacité à porter une voix spécifique
sur des faits sur des problématiques et
sur des conflits donc voilà quells
étaient mes deux question à votre
attention je vous remercie Pierre
uas merci monsieur le Président je je
voudrais vraiment vous remercier très
sincèrement pour la qualité de de votre
propos et moi j'aimerais m'associer avec
les collègues au remerciement que nous
formulons pour toutes les personnes qui
sont sur sur le
terrain je ne sais pas comment elles
font pour vivre ça moi j'avoue que je
suis dans l'incapacit de regarder le
journal télévisé tellement les images
sont
bouleversantes abominables des deux
côtés je j'ai du mal à mettre à leur
place et et à vivre psychologiquement ce
qu'il pourrait vivre je je pense qu'il
faut croire vraiment dans dans leur
métier dans l'utilité du du journalisme
et aussi dans la force de ce qui nous
transmett parce que
fait expérience de regarder une chaîne
katari et vous comprendrez quelle est la
force incroyable de ces
images quand on fait un choix de de
présenter certaines images et pas
d'autres on peut on peut dresser des
population entière contre les uns et
contre les autres donc vous avez une
responsabilité qui est monstrueuse et
que je n'aimerais pas
assumer je fais un pas de côté euh en en
vous parlant d'un autre d'un autre
conflit qui est malheureusement
complètement sorti de l'actualité c'est
celui de l'artsar du
haaraba j'ai lu avec beaucoup
d'attention vos vos dépêches vous
n'utilisez jamais le mot Zard si ce
n'est quand il est prononcé par les
Arméniens eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire que
vous vous estimez mais comme la plupart
des pays et la France la première je
vous en fais pas le reproche que le le
référendum de 95 par lequel le peuple
arartsariote a défini son son
indépendance est nul et non avenu et et
donc vous vous présentez l'artsar comme
une république autoproclamée ce qui est
rigoureusement le langage de
l'Azerbaïjan mais mais encore une fois
je vous en fait pas le le reproche ce
que j'aimerais comprendre c'est dans le
choix des mots que vous faites parce que
là le mot est essentiel quand vous dites
Arabat quand vous dites harzar vous
prenez parti pour l'un ou l'autre camp
et j'aimerais savoir quel est le le
processus intellectuel et le processus
collégial aussi parce que je je suppose
que c'est une décision collégial qui
fait que vous choisissez un un mot
plutôt plutôt qu'un autre et comment
ensuite vous le justifiez à l'exéilleur
parce que par exemple c'est quelque
chose que que je n'ai pas trouvé sur sur
votre site pourquoi vous n'utilisez pas
le le le le le mot
SAR donc c'est c'est ça que j'aimerais
comprendre parce que peut-être que ça
permettrait aussi un éclairage sur la
façon dont vous voulez ou pas utiliser
le mot terroriste qui qui lui aussi
renvoie une nomenclature internationale
à des règles de droit donc c'est ça qui
m'intéresserait je vous remercie Bernard
fieller merci monsieur le Président donc
moi aussi j'ajoute un petit peu tout le
respect qu'on a pour pour les gens qui
qui risquent leur vie pour pouvoir nous
nous informer moi c'est une question
simple dans Pr longement de Cell qui ont
été posé vous nous dites que votre ligne
éctoriale vous vous interdit d'utiliser
le mot terroriste qui est un mot
pourtant qui existe dans la lang
française je vous avez d'autres exemples
de mots qui sont comme ça que
vous qui sont affichés comme nétant pas
possible d'être utilisé par vos lignes
électorales
merci moi aussi je vais ajouter quelques
question dans un souci de de
compréhension et peut-être de réponse à
des à des polémiques bon on a beaucoup
parlé du du mot terroriste on a compris
à travers vos tribunes que derrière
l'utilisation du mot terroriste la la la
la la crainte que vous avez c'est de
prendre parti dans une situation qui est
est parfois complexe à analyser dans
dans l'instant mais une fois que cela a
été jugé est-ce que vous avez les les
mêmes réserves pour utiliser le
beterrorisme je pense en particulier aux
auteurs des attentats du du Bataclan il
y a eu un procès la justice française
c'est c'est prononcé et bien pour des
actes de terrorisme est-ce que dans ces
cas-là votre règle
rédactionnelle vous permet de de
d'utiliser le mot
terroriste dans le prolongement de la la
la question de de Bernard fialer sur
d'autres mots sur lequel vous avez des
des réserves la presse F écho de de
consigne
interne demandant de ne pas utiliser le
terme islamiste du Hamas mais combattant
du Hamas est-ce que vous pourriez nous
préciser si c'est bien une consigne à ce
moment nous donner aussi des éléments de
d'explication de même sur les élément
d'explication on a bien noté ce que vous
nous avez dit monsieur le Président
sur sur le le raté comme vous l'avez dit
concernant le
euh la la la non communication des
images transmises par tal en tout cas
pas dans de manière rapide euh est-ce
que il y a eu aussi des question sur le
traitement ou le temps relativement long
pour
traiter ce qui s'est passé lors de la
rêve partie est-ce que vous pourriez
nous donner des des explications de même
sur l'invasion de l'aéroport au dagastan
qui a donné lieu à un certain nombre
d'interrogation sur une autre ordre de
questions euh vous n avez dit que vous
avez une cinquantaine de de journalistes
permanents sur sur place h à Gaza euh je
crois que les journalistes à Gaza sont
tous Palestiniens est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire un peu quelles sont
les règles que vous appliquez
euh pour envoyer des locaux ou des des
gens d'autres pays en fonction des des
des zones et des tensions existante euh
et puis peut-être une
une une question qui va nous éloigner un
petit peu mais vous avez dit qu'il y
avait les mêmes règles entre les trois
grandes agences internationales deux
sont américaines une est française
est-ce que finalement dans cette
uniformisation des règles d'usage des
mots est-ce que il y a pas un peu une
perte de la spécificité d'être une
agence
française si je crois que l'essentiel
des questions est pour ça oui ok
euh oui je vais revenir sur la question
des des des chiffres euh utilisés par
tous les gros médias
euh de Gaza euh c'est les chiffres qui
vient de l'autorité euh hospitalière à
Gaza bien sûr sous le contrôle de Hamas
sous l'administration de Hamas
euh il faut distinguer distinguer là que
Hamas il y a la partie militaire il y a
partie politique et puis il y a
l'administration les chiffres qui
viennent de partie de l'administration
notamment autour de de qui viennent des
des hôpitaux et cetera sont considérés
comme fiables par l'ONU par les ONG qui
travaille là-bas ils sont très détaillés
euh on a des des noms des nombres de
famille
euh après
euh il y a niveau de détail ils sont
utilisés dans les rapports
gouvernementals euh ils sont pas
énormément contestés par les
israéliensnes EU je sais que c'est
président Biden qui a fait un
commentaire là-dessus mais c'était très
intéressant que juste la semaine il y a
deux TR jours un membre de l'équipe
Biden a dit en fait
que il était on a cité sur le fil la FP
que le chif est probablement beaucoup
trop bas en fait qu' y a des gens sous
les bâtiments et cetera
h on a écrit des explications sur
comment on utilise ces chiffres je pense
les société de Press a fait la même
chose euh et je pense même les gens de
l'ONU a parlé depuis encore une fois sur
la la la fiabilité de ces chiffres bien
sûr parfois c'est ça ça ça va être dans
une situation comme on vit maintenant
parfois des estimations euh mais ils
sont largement considérés euh comme
fiables
et est-ce qu'on a la capacité de fa
checker sur le terrain toutes les ces
détails et cetera non là où on a des
problèmes et c'était écrit dans notre
copie euh dans les chiffres ils disent
jamais bien sûr qu's sont des
combattants
euh ils communiqueent beaucoup sur la
quantité
d'enfants c'est pas surprenant étant
donné le le le mix de la population il y
a énormément de jeunes qui visent à à
Gaza on peut pas être sûr de la quantité
mais tout ce que je peux dire c'est nos
journalistes eux-mêmes dans les hôpitaux
dans les morgues dans la rue ont vu
certainement des centaines et des
centaines d'enfants blessés et et morts
je peux pas aller plus loin que que que
ça
euh mais comme j'ai dit c'est c'est
c'est ces chiffres sont sont utilisés
par par beaucoup beaucoup de médias
organisation euh les ONG et et et l'ONU
euh et c'est à cause de ça je pense que
on revient sur cet incident à l'hôpital
à que beaucoup de médias a repris cette
info
euh il y avait encore une fois
différentes sources pour cette info sur
la frappe de l'hôpital il y avait une
communiqué qui vient de la partie
militaire de Hamas qu'on a pas touché
qui a parlé de de 500 morts euh il y a
une communiquée qui vient de système
hospitalier qui qui a parlé de je pense
quelques centaines morts qu'on a
repris
sorcé c'était c'était comme on fait
assez souvent avec une allégation
c'était clairement sorcé à à
l'administration médicale sous contrôle
de Hamas
euh
alors est-ce qu'on aura le luxe de ne
pas traiter cette info non parce que ça
part c'est c'est c'est c'est sur toutes
les chaînes en boucle arabe c'est sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est notre boulot
d'y aller et de contextualiser et et et
et de faire notre boulot de de
vérification et
contextualisation on aurait dû être plus
prudent dans la manière dont on a on a
écrit La Dépêche on aurait dû être plus
ferme sur le fait que AFP était pas sur
place que AFP était pas en mesure de
confirmer l'allégation de de Hamas parce
que céta c une allégation qui était très
gros la formulation des mots était pas
parfait on a changé nos consigne après
pour juste changer la manière dont on
formule certaines choses quand on pasle
de de
Hamas et après la complexité c'était
euh l'attente pour pour vraiment la
partie israélienne on a eu une réaction
assez rapide des israélien qui dit on
est en train de de regarder mais ça a
pris 3 He pour avoir le contenarratif et
3 He dans le temps réel et c'est toute
la complexité du travail de la FP c'est
le travail de temps réel 3h dans le
temps réel c'est c'est énorme c'est
énorme mais bien sûr dès qu'on a eu la
réaction israélienne on on a alerté on a
on a complètement changé la manière
d'écrire les dépêches on a on a on on a
fait
tout mais c'est ce 3 He qui qui qui qui
est compliqué
et c'est quelque chose que j'ai discuté
avec mes mes mes
homologues et et il y a pas une solution
très simple à ça parce que c'est c'est
le contexte dans lequel on travaille le
contexte des réseaux le contexte de de
de de voilà de l'information qu' qu'on
maîtrise pas c'est pas les agences
maintenant qui maîtrisent la diffusion
de l'info l'info partte immédiatement
sur les réseau après on chasse après
pour contextualiser mais comme j'ai dit
on aurait dû l'écrire dans une manière
plus prudent est-ce que ça aurait changé
la narratif je suis pas convaincu mais
on sera plus ferme plus content chez
nous si si on a écrit différemment et si
ça passe en une deuxième fois on la
traite différemment
euh sur le mot terroriste
oui c'est possible de trouver sur le fil
AFP sur les images AFP sur les vidéos
AFP toutes les tweets AFP des milli mil
et des millions de
documents des exemples où le style est
pas respecté parfois le style pour le
président français ou le style pour
comment traiter les immigrants ou le
style ça c'est un boulot en permanence à
FP on a un énorme manuel de l'agencier
que chaque journaliste àp est censé à
comprendre lire tout le
temps on a des nouveaux entrants on a
parfois des stagiaires on a parfois des
des gens qui sont parassux on a des des
gens qui sont moins bons que d'autres ah
il y a des erres le fait qu'on trouve le
mot terroriste s guillemet sur notre fil
c'est c'est c'est pas
surprenant mais je je prends vraiment
les questions l'inverse il y a
99,9 % des des situations o le mot c'est
déployé sur le sur le fil c'est dans un
contexte correct et aussi il faut dire
que le mot est partout tout parce que
tout le monde l'utilise tout le monde
l'utilise les les gouvernements
autoritaires voilà
les voilà ça ça ça c'est c'est c'est
partout sur notre
fille non mais c'est mais c'est juste
pour dire que le mot est est vraiment le
mot est vraiment partout et c'est c'est
ça parti de raison on est obligé
d'arriver avec un style parce que non
après les événements de 11 septembre
c'était dans la la bouche de vraiment
tout le monde et c'était extrêmement
difficile de de de de faire une
politique de en fait de décider qui qui
est terroriste et qui est pas terroriste
là les opposants de de de Monsieur
Bachar al-Assad les opposants de
Monsieur Bachar alAssad c'est des gens
proches d'alqaïda monsieur Bachar
alAssad utilise des es chimiques contre
sa propre population mais qui qui est le
terroriste c'est extrêmement difficile
d'arriver à à à à
choisir on éétait pas on nétait pas en
Syrie on étiit on était au lendemain
d'une opération qui était épouvantable
j'espère que vous avez vu les images qui
ont été projetées soit hier à
l'Assemblée nationale oou il y a
quelques jours dans dans d'autres lieux
où le caractère
terroriste la caractérisation d'une
attaque terroriste avec ces choses
abominables ne font pas de DUP c'est
vraiment c'est le sens commun qui permet
de le qualifier aussi et c'est le enfin
la France le festival était un Bataclan
en grand un batclan un Bataclan à ciel
ouvert non on couvre des choses
abominables partout dans le monde chaque
semaine c'est c'est ça notre difficulté
juste quand on a eu cette discussion
juste avant le le le Bataclan en fait
parce
que la semaine avant ou quelques
semaines avant il y avait 200 enfants
tués dans dans une école dans le nord de
Pakistan pas utilise le mot dans ces
circonstances là on a pe utiliser le mot
dans dans batlan on on n pas utilisé des
mots quand il y a 1500 personnes tué
dans le nord de Mozambique il inclut 400
qui sont décapités c'est c'est c'est des
choses qu'on couvre partout dans le
monde tout le temps qui est très très
très difficile bah juste pour revenir
sur la
politique comme j'ai dit c'était en face
qu'on a eu les attendats de Paris et
Charlie Hebdo on n pas eu le polémique
publque qu'on a maintenant c'est quelque
chose qui est respecté par toutes les
gros médias globales du monde
et c'est pas pour suivre les autres
médias qu'on le fait mais c'est c'est
c'est c'est pour les bonnes
raisons et une chose que je dirais c'est
aussi pour
protéger nos équipes sur le terrain le
moment on commence à décrire les taliban
par exemple en Afghanistan comme des
terroristes on mett une CIB sur le dos
de toutes nos journ là-bas on ferme le
bureau il y a beaucoup d'endroits où
peut dire la même chose et ça on est
assz unique les grosses agences d'avoir
beaucoup de journalistes dans des
situations de précarité partout dans le
monde on faisait un boulot très
difficile dans dans un contexte très
difficile on a perdu nous-même des
journalistes qui ét tué par l'État
islamique par le taliban en Afghanistan
et en Syrie
et on gère très bien les les les bah
avec difficulté mais on sait très bien
les difficultés qui qui en face de de
nos journalistes et ça ça joue aussi
dans dans nos nos décisions
euh si je comment on
décide d'avoir cette politique eu on a
des journalistes qui gèent les les
standards leséthique euh les questions
déontologiques il y a un réseau de ces
journalistes dans tous les gros médias
du monde qui qui en parle beaucoup
euh et c'est une discussion qui que
qu'on a euh entre entre nous à l'agence
avec toutes les équipes chef h et il y a
pas énormément debat en terne à l'agence
sur ces questions même si chaque fois
qu'on a une histoire proche de nous on
comprend parfaitement euh l'émotion
c'est voilà euh c'est exactement la même
chose pour nous qu'on a perdu nos
propres journalistes dans des attentats
c'est c'est très difficile
euh sur la question de les les les
sources sur le terrain si on parle de ce
que se passe à
Gaza on en nos propres journalistes qui
sont basés là-bas qui ont le réseau de
contact qui connait un peu le
terrain mais la
difficulté ça c'est aussi un élément de
contexte très important pour pour
l'incident à
l'hôpital c'était pas fa possible d'y
aller immédiatement c'était extrêmement
dangereux c'était toute la zone où o où
l'armée israélienne a dit c'est exclus
d'être là si vous êtes là vous êtes une
cible ça veut dire que c'était pas
possible juste d'y aller immédiatement
et regarder ce que se passe on est allé
le jour après et même là c'était
dangereux il y avait déjà des des
frappes autour de nos équipes moi moi
j'étais pas à l'aise avec le fait qu'on
y aller mais ils sont très courageux ils
sont allés là-bas vraiment pour pour
filmer pour interviever pour essayer de
comprendre et on a travaillé sur une
grosse enquête sur sur sur ces
questionslà pour essayer de comprendre
avec vraiment des des des témoignages
des des l'équipe qui travaille sur les
réseaux on on a fait une grosse enquête
pour pour pour comprendre ce que s'est
passé mais mais mais il faut comprendre
que c'est extrêmement difficile de de
faire les chos qu'on veut faire le plus
c'est de témoigner nous-même sur des
choses qui se passent parce qu' il y a
toujours cette menace notamment dans
dans le nord de Gaza euh à Gaza City
après tous nos journ les travaille avec
les mêm codes diontologique que que que
tous les autres journalistes à la FP il
sont tous formés avec les mêmes règles
on fait des formations régulières
souvent les chefs de poste de
Jérusalem temp normal moi je suis
moi-même aller à Gaza dans le passé pour
visiter notre équipe encore une fois
pour diffuser la culture de
l'agence et encore une fois toute
l'information passe via nos nos
journalistes à Jérusalem c'est c'est pas
il y a tout un système d'édition qui
passe ver jusem et puis unikouszi euh
pour veiller sur sur sur la qualité euh
de de ce que ils sont en train de faire
c'est une équipe qui est avec nous
depuis longtemps beaucoup d'ux ont gagné
des prix euh autour du monde ils sont
bien connus euh
et euh oui c'est comme ça qu'on
travaille
euh en terme
de la sécurité euh oui on a une grosse
frustration en ce
moment ça honnête qu'on peut pas faire
grand-chose pour eux normalement la
sécurité des des journalistes à la FP
c'est quelque chose qu'on qu'on qu'on
suit en temps réel des formations des
des voilà des des analyses de risque sur
chaque mission et cetera et cetera mais
là pour notre équipe à Gaza la guerre
est chez eux et ils sont enfermés dans à
Gaza ça ve ils ont pas l'option de
sortir et nous nous n'avons pas l'option
de de d'entrer à Gaza qui est un peu
différent des des autres conflits qu'on
a eu à Gaza et ça va dire dans le
contexte actuel il y il y a très peu de
choses qu'on peut faire pour eux et ça
ça ça fait mal au cœur on on reçoit des
des des messages de assez désespéré
comme j'ai dit ils ont perdu des membres
de la famille beaucoup d'amis beaucoup
de collègues et cetera et c'est c'est
c'est c'est pas facile pour eux
euh en tant que je pense que je viens la
la question question sur
l'Arménie bah je prendre l'exemple par
exemple de de la question de
génocide pourquoi euh on utilise pas le
mot génocide dans le contexte d'Arménie
mais on utilise pas bien sûr pour pour
le choix pour Rwanda et même sur Ben et
c'est parce que c'est reconnu par l'ONU
et même s'il y a des des des pays qui
qui qui reconnaît qu'il y avait une
génocide en Arménie euh c'est pas
quelque chose qui est reconnu par le on
est obligé de trouver des sources qui
qui fait l' et et c'est même chose en
fait sur sur sur sur pour le terrorisme
il faut le dire même si les États-Unis
et et l'Europe utilise le mot terroriste
pour certains ces groupes là c'est ça
fait pas unanime tu vois et euh ça ça ça
qui complique les choses il y a toujours
un process de dialogue pendant toute
cette phase de de la guerre en nagorni
karabak Arménie on a on a reçu
l'ambassadrice arménienne plusieurs fois
discuter parfois on a juste des phrases
tu vois comment comment faire des choses
on est on est toujours à l'écoute des
différentes communautés et certainement
on a changé certaines conses dans la
manière dont on parle des séparatistes
en Arménie pour pour dire que des
séparatistes c'est que des gens qui les
combattants effectivement ok je pour
être sûr que c'est pas le reste de la
population on parle pas de toute la
population comme des séparatistes mais
mais mant juste les com ça va dire on
est toujours en train d'affiner changer
adapter et cetera parce qu'on sait dans
le contexte actuel les mots sont sont
extrêmement sensibles
euh honnêtement en tête sur la question
de d'un autre exemple du mot j'en suis
sûr il y en a
euh mais j'ai j'ai pas un autre mot en
tête mais pardon je je j'en suis sûr
qu'il y en
a mais mais j'ai pas réponse simple à
ces questions là
euh et et encore une fois sur comment on
utilise le mot sur la question thorque
si c'est quelqu'un jugé par un tribunal
français je reviens la question que
avant c'est c'est pas juste parce que
une instance dans un pays a décidé qu'
quelqu'un teroriste qu'on qu'on va
changer notre notre
politique comment on décrit les les les
les attaques hamass on essaie d'utiliser
des des mots différentses ça ça dépend
du contexte c'est
pas c'est c'est pas il y a des contextes
où c'est intéressant de parler de Hamas
en tant qu'islamiste notamment dans un
contexte politique ça dépend de de de
quel quel quel est quel le contexte euh
il y a pas de règle ferme de de de de de
dire une chose et pas d'autre mais de
trouver des moyens et encore une fois ce
qu'on demande dans nos équipes c'est
vraiment de témoigner en fait quand on
parle là de de par exemple le
terrorisme en fait le défi c'est de de
lire notre copie lire notre copie tout
ce qu'on a décrit dans le sud d'Israël
dans les kibuts dans partout mais c'est
c'est des choses atroces qui qui sont
décrits avec des mots qui qui qui
rendent absolument clair que c'est
atroce et que c'est c'est c'est
dégueulasse c'est c'est c'est le mot
terroriste en fait apporte absolument
rien à nos description c'est ce qu'on
privilége toujours de raconter ce qu'on
voit et je pense si les gens prendent un
peu de temps de lire toutes les
reportages qu'on a fait sur ces C cet
attentat on continue de faire les
reportages avec les rescapés de de rave
party avec les les rescap des avec les
les familles des otages avec voilà ce
qui se'est passé à Sidro dans dans dans
le sud je pense que tout ça est clair
euh je reviens sur la question des
projections l'image les images euh bah
juste en terme de contexte avant qu'on
parle d'image parce que c'était après je
pense 2 semaines on a eu cet événement
juste pour dire que euh l'après-midi de
le 7 octobre il y avait des photograph
et des vidé d'p àidro dans le Sud qui a
filmé eux-même des images atroces qu'on
a envoyé toutes mes 4000 clients autour
du monde notment des gens qui étaient
abattus là en attendant pour un bus dans
le voiture c'est très difficile à
regarder ces images ça veut dire que
voilà l'idée qu'on a un peu fait
l'impasse sur les images difficiles non
dès le premier jour on a fait des images
très difficiles nous-mêm et aussi équipe
é en train de interacter avec des images
atroces filmé par Hamas qui ét mis sur
les
réseaux on a aussi sourcé des images qui
sont venu des des autorités israéliennes
notamment les les gens qui sont sur le
terrain pour pour pour gérer les corps
et cetera on a passé beaucoup d'images
photos et vidéos à nos clients des
images difficiles qui vient parfois des
des GoPro caméras de Hamas et cetera ça
veut dire même avant cette projection on
a fourni des chose atroce à à à à nos
clients et nous journal étaient en train
d'interacter avec ces
images si je viens à à ce ce cet
incident ça ça arrive ça arrive avec la
fatigue je pense que je peux dire que
les projections étaient plutôt organisé
par les 2000 journalistes qui sont
entrés en Israël après les attentats
faut dire notre équipe a pas pris de
jours de repos rien pour 2 semaines qui
bossent des des jours de 18 20h par jour
oui dans dans dans ces circonstances
parfois on fait un mauvais jugement on
dit euh tiens ok on prend des des
éléments de ça on utilise dans un papier
de main on parfois on mesure pas euh le
fait que le nos collègues vont vont vont
vont écrire quelque chose ou vont les
traiter différemment mais en fait
comment on a réagi après on a réagi
après en deux trois fois on a écrit sur
ces images même ce matin parce que je
pense qu'il y a une projection avec des
députés aujourd'hui on a refait
l'histoire ce matin on a il y a 600 mon
s notre fille aujourd'hui qui est juste
une description de ce que s'est passé
dans dans ce film je P on peut pas dire
qu'on a fait l'impasse sur ces images le
fait que on fait des erreurs humaines
erreurs de jugement dans la fatigue et
cetera c'est c'est juste normal ça ça ça
arrive c'est humain pour des gens qui
bossent vraiment
comme comme j'ai dit sans cesse pour 2
semaines 20h par
jour après le Dagestan Dagestan c'est
c'est un exemple très intéressant
je pense notre défi comme j'ai dit c'est
de parler de on travaille dans le temps
réel qui est pas tout est pas toujours
clair dans le temps réel on sait pas ce
que se passe dans le temps réel le jour
après sur les platees télé c'est très
très clair tout est très clair on a on a
on a 18h 15h de de d'information on peut
rassembler quelque chose 15h après qui
est très clair mais dans dans le temps
réel les premières sources qu'on a eu
sur les choses qui se passent en
dagistan comme on avait pas encore
correspondant à l'aéroport à l'époque
c'était les médias
russes et les images non vérifiées sur
les réseaux
sociaux Paron sur telgram ouais réseaux
sociaux russes ça veut dire que il faut
traiter avec le maximum de prudence
c'est des choses qu'on pas vérifier
nous-mêm mais si on prend la différence
entre ce qu'on a écrit au début qui est
extrêmement prudent qu'est-ce que se
passe on on décrit ce que se passe sans
sans sans tout le contexte savoir et ce
qu'on a écrit 8h plus tard il y a pas
photo parce qu' après il y a la Maison
Blanche qui a parlé de progrom il y a la
réaction de Premier ministre israélienne
Benjamin nanahou on était capable de de
de le faire d'une manière complètement
différente et en plus qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait le jour après et je pense qu'il y a
pas autres médias qui qui ont fait ce
boulot on a fait un reportage sur la
communauté juif en Russie les les les
craintes et les les les les les
le le situation là et aussi ici en
France en même temps je pense il y a pas
un autre média qui a fait ça et ça va
dire les critiques sur ces couverture je
les comprends pas du tout c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est malhonnête c'est des
gens qui prendnent un capture d'écran de
quelque chose qui qui se passe en temps
réel et le jour après il dit ah oui
tiens vous avez pas décrit ça comme
comme il faut mais il faut regarder la
totalité de la couverture ça c'est notre
boulot l'effet de vraiment vérifier tout
avant de faire voilà des conclusions et
c'est ce qu'on a fait en fa fait notre
boulot très bien dans dans cette
histoire je vais prendre comme ça tu
peux boire un peu euh une une des
questions que vous avez posé votre
dernière question monsieur le Président
sur l'identité française de l'AFP
euh on je pense que on a pris cette
décision je n'y étais pas à l'époque
mais F il était à l'agence elle a été
prise en toute autonomie on s'est pas
concerté
euh associété de presse et retterce
auraiit pris une autre mesure je suis
pas sûr qu'on se serait aligné sur eux
euh encore une fois je pense que si tout
le monde en est arrivé à cette
conclusion c'est parce que on fait le
même métier mais je me suis déjà
expliqué là-dessus on va pas répéter en
revanche l'identité française elle je
dirais même plutôt plus largement
l'identité européenne parce qu'on est
effectivement la seule européenne des
trois mondiales elle est très forte et
c'est euh on n pas la voix de la France
mais on est un regard européen sur
l'actu et joue un peu sur les
mots et ça c'est une ça se voit tous les
jours dans les reportages qu'on fait
c'est-à-dire d'abord sur la présence
terrain nos concurrents vont aller se
concentrer sur les régions qui
intéressent leurs
clients nous on a une présence vraiment
mondiale et dans le choix des sujets
qu'on prend je pense qu'on va les
traiter
différemment de la manière dont ils sont
traités par par nos concurrents et donc
on est assez fier de ce de cette
identité européenne on la refoule
absolument pas et on ne cherche à aucun
moment de
s'aligner sur nos
conurs je crois c'est important de le le
le
redire une dernière question de de
Pierre-Antoine lev oui merci Monsieur
président pr monsieur le le Président
Monsieur directeur d'information
permettez-moi de vous dire que j'étais
assez mal à l'aise en écoutant les
explications je ne sais pas si je suis
le seul en vous entendant essayz de
justifier le fait que vous n'appeliez
pas ne qualifiez pas parce que c'est pas
dans votre règle de qualifier le le mot
de terroriste or vous l'avez fait avec
par plusieurs plusieurs fois dans le
passé comme l'a indiqué Bruno rotaillo
vous l'avez fait également sur Al-Qaïda
peut-être que si il avait été indiqué
que le ramas était une organisation
terroriste c'est aussi un moyen de
différencier le peuple palestinien du
Hamas ce qui est pas le cas normalement
et aujourd'hui qui qui en paye qui paye
les conséquences je je trouve très
surprenant que que cette charte
s'applique encore parce que il y a pas
de difficulté à qualifier un acte de
terroriste quand il est un acte de
terroriste comment qualifieriez-vous si
un journaliste de la FP était assassiné
dans le cadre d'un attentat terroriste
qu'est-ce que vous diriez est-ce que
c'est un attentat terroriste on pas
qualifié de terroriste dans les les cas
qu' cité fil n'a pas utilisé ce mot il
on a parlé d'un attentat djihadiste en
l'occurrence cétait beaucoup plus précis
oui mais c'est un acte quand même
terroriste il me semble le c'est un
meurtre c'est un massacre c'est un une
attaque à l'arme blanche c'est une
décapitation oui il y a plein de mots
qui peuvent être utilisé qui sont tout
oui mais pour le grand public monsieur
le Président et ça a choqué beaucoup de
personnes ça a choqué parce que on n'est
pas là pour faire le le procè la FP on
est là pour essayer de comprendre ça a
choqué beaucoup de personnes que lafp ne
qualifie pas cet acte de TER teriste
tout simplement parce que c'est un acte
de terrorisme comme c'était un acte de
terrorisme B je voudrais vous poser une
question à côté de ça sur les propos
dont vous avez parlé tout à l'heure sur
les les accusations d'antisémitisme d'un
député récemment vous avvez indiqué que
s'il ne retirez pas ces propos vous
porteriez plainte où est-ce que vous
pouvez nous indiquer où on en est
aujourd'hui sur cette
affaire il ne les a pas retiré donc nous
allons porter
plainte par
ailleurs sa
pas moi je suis un peu décontenané parce
qu'on passe des heures à s'expliquer sur
ce sujet encore une fois faut ramener le
sujet à à des vraies proportions on
n'hésite pas à dire les atrocités on l'a
dit avec des mots qui sont qu'on juge
précis d'accord on n'empêche aucun média
d'utiliser le mot terroriste les médias
sont nos clients encore une fois on
s'adresse pas au grands public on
s'adresse aux médias les médias ils
veulent des choses extrêmement précises
précise ils veulent savoir qui parle sur
le la qualification du Hamas comme
organisation terroriste comme la dit fil
le sud global on va le dire comme ça ne
ne reconnaît pas le Hamas comme
organisation terroriste ça compte ça
compte donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait on dit
le Hamas qui est reconnu comme
organisation terroriste par l'Union
européenne les États-Unis et Israël et
cetera et cetera et qui par ailleurs ne
reconnaît pas le droit d'Israël à
exister bon s où le problème les médias
sont assez grands pour faire ce qu'ils
veulent derrière donc vous aurez le
monde qui ira dire que c'est un groupe
terroriste peut-être tel autre médiia
dans une autre région ne le qualifiera
pas de tel et choisira ses mots mais les
les médias sont assez grands pour le
faire et les médias je je n'ai pas
connaissance peut-être qu'en faisant
cette déclaration je vais avir je vais
appeler à des à des réactions mais les
médias ne ne ne nous ont fait aucun pour
eux c'est c'est ce n'est pas un sujet
donc on on est on monte en épingle un
sujet depuis des semaines c'est quand
même dingue c'est dingue faut
arrêter à aucun moment on ne ni les
atrocités du 7 octobre on on vous dit
que même lors des attentats de Charlie
sur notre sol F était rédacteur en chef
la c'était une directrice de
l'information française qui était à
l'époque le débat était tranché en ce
sens il y a pas eu de polémique il y a
pas eu de polémique donc pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y en aurait une
aujourd'hui je je peut-être je veux
juste ajouter qu' encore une fois il y a
a y a il y a aucune différence il y a
pas dans la manière dont on on traite
amas que la manière dont on traite
alqaïda j'ai pas même essayé de regarder
sur 20 ans si quelqu'un a utilisé le mot
terroriste s les millions de document
qu'on a passé sur Hamas peut-être ça
existe parce que encore une fois quand
on passe autant de contenu avec des gens
qui travaillent partout dans le
monde c'est ça ça va arriver mais la
politique est absolument la même pour
pour pour pour
tous bien messieur merci de de de ces
répones du temps que vous nous avez euh
donné pour essayer d'apporter